hey everyone welcome to epi from comicon
right now I'm Lana Galera what's the one
the only the Catholic Marvel's the
defenders hey guys I if you're here
right now I am so thrilled for this new
show because we have daredevil Iron Fist
Luke Cage Jessica Jones all coming
together for the very first time how
ethics will this Union be so that took
my word I was going to be episode the
what can you tease about this series is
one of the most highly anticipated
Marvel series of all time well let's
look this is a dream that comes true
what happened was we went to Netflix we
had this incredibly unprecedented idea
which was to do four television series
all by themselves so each of them would
have their own stories with remarkable
cast and great writing and then it was
all going to join together and Marco
Ramirez our showrunner had to figure out
how to put the puzzle together and he
said here you go here's the box there's
no map no game the piece is no box the
promise isn't and you guys don't work Oh
Marco goes Marco we are finally going to
be seen all four of these action heroes
in the same room together
what would your goal with this series I
guess the goal was just to make sure
that they all won every argument they
had with each other it's really about
kind of maybe the audience loves these
characters and nobody wants to feel like
they came to this and and their favorite
person isn't being served so really it
feels like the big challenge is making
it you know keeping the keeping the
balance of all four of them really
shining as often as they could and these
actors I think did a great job how long
do we have to wait before we get the
four part team up is it a couple
episodes is going to go right away I am
you know I'm just some bloggers will
tell you
but who would you say is the most
reluctant out of the four to join the
team up because I think I feel like with
the one of the great things about the
show is that you've got four people have
got no interest in being part of a team
and then so the challenge that of course
maka
accomplish wonders please how do you get
those four people into room and then how
do you get it to stay there and new
really want to be there but that but
also Jessica Joe what is good with me I
feel like someone has to be that guy
because otherwise you'll never you'll
never get it done you know someone has
to be that guy we're four loners who all
have our own thing going and we kind of
like you know taking attention from that
to do something that we didn't even know
about so it's you know someone has to be
the driving force and that's what then
he does and then there's the other side
of it which is that there has to be an
antagonist which forces them all
together and so on the one hand
incredibly lucky to have Sigourney
Weaver and then on the other hand the
supposedly dead Elektra mm returns I was
going to say look at me from zombie
Elektra very bloody very dark and extra
this season was that fun for you to be
able to have that additional layer to
her definitely yeah it's because you you
know go back to a character that you
like loved and then just explore
different do different aspects of
personality yes
definitely and of course the one and
only Colleen is going to be there to
help as well
she is quite kick-ass in her own right
how does she get in with the dynamic of
the group I think she's kind of just
reeling from everything that happened in
iron fist as good as I do then she's got
to get to terms of that over the course
of defenders and also obviously she's
trying to help Danny I think she's a bit
untrusting is this such a rich quartet
she's always been his right-hand
right-hand man it's kind of like why are
you abandoning me for these losers
[Applause]
chocolate they ain't talking to me
wait jess is eyes you just officially
announcing that we will get a season to
defend his markers not doing anything
what are you doing to 2021 look that's
up to the fans and up to our friends at
Netflix it's totally happening oh the
one early warning Weaver playing your
villain but she has recently spoken out
in Spanish she's not so much a villain
but in adversary to the group how would
you describe her dynamic what did you
tender bracelet embracing how would you
say she compares to other Marvel
adversaries out there that we've seen in
the past
mostly Sigourney Weaver no she's weird
icon in the genre and for everybody men
and women so having her she just got
like a fierce Grace and a presence and
you know you can't really even compare
Sigourney Weaver to anybody recently is
the official Marvel's defenders Facebook
page posted a comment talking about
spider guy and a lot of fans out there
are wondering if that is an odd that the
defenders know of spider
you know New York isn't that big of a
city oh I don't know I don't know
anything about that but no spider ha ha
ha
look at you're just trying to in some
trouble so that obviously stuck with
hashtag it's all connected
yeah but look it is I mean at the end of
the day they do all live in the same
world but as we've said from the very
beginning the Avengers are interested in
saving the universe and and the
defenders and individually each of these
characters are more interested in saving
whether it's the neighborhood and in
many cases this lady's yourself just
like violently you know in the end of
the days and in many ways that can be
equally compelling yeah I mean as
remember the front cover of one of the
magazines are sorry one of the comic
books having Luke Cage uppercut
spider-man so if you've ever in the
neighborhood I'd be happy to punch him
just you know just saw the Lederman
stories no the other one did everything
and now it's just Luke Cage going to
fight fight now it's saying is he was in
the neighborhood at some point right
punch it you static wait let's just put
it back dad if we look it making a bunch
of real quick oh we did see in the epic
defenders trailer the Huns jog it's a
little smushed by a certain Iron Fist I
didn't feel a thing
we did you were complaining about how
much it hurt every time I could know
that was what he kicked me because he
already kicked me you want to pull back
in stock world you don't know you can
handle it after 40 questions in the same
spot it starts to wear on you where the
politics inside of not politics lastly
what is the one thing that you want
Marvel fans to know before they tune in
to the defenders in August
watch it all in one weekend yeah where
are you preparing to bingeing
it's 8:00 tomorrow it's a gray day yes
so do you recommend me to sit down for
the long haul one day I think they're
going to get up at the end of the day
once you watch one you're in there learn
everyone knows you're like cookie thank
you all so much for stopping by a cheese
kamikaze I really appreciate it for all
you fans out there make sure you tune in
to Marvel's the defenders to see all
these amazing people team up check but
and save New York thanks so much
make sure you like subscribe all that
good stuff where we come to you live
from Comic Con all weekend
[Music]